hey I'm Mel strong and this lecture is
on evaporation in latent heat we're
gonna start by looking at phase
transitions of water molecules so here
I've got a simulation from Phet and what
we're looking at are a bunch of water
molecules that are in a container that
we can see through and we talked about
this before but water molecules have
hydrogen on one side of the oxygen so
they kind of have this Mickey Mouse head
appearance to them so if you notice that
the water molecules right now are not
perfectly still
they're jiggling around a little bit
they're vibrating what we would say is
that they have vibrational energy now
despite the fact that they're moving a
little bit if you watch one for a long
time you'll notice that even though it's
vibrating it's not really changing its
position it doesn't really move very far
and it does not change position with its
neighbors okay I want to add a little
bit of heat okay so and I've warmed it
up and so the water molecules now look
nervous they are vibrating more and they
have more vibrational energy so this is
true with all atoms and molecules at
Absolute Zero which is zero degrees
Kelvin which is the coldest possible
temperature all motion stops and all
atoms and all molecules cease to vibrate
but at any of the temperature there's
some vibration of all substances now the
one where I make it the more vibrational
energy they have so despite the fact
that these guys are now vibrating more
you'll also notice that they still don't
really change the position with their
neighbors they stay bonded with their
neighbors also I want to point out these
holes this one that one that one a
little one down there okay keep keep an
eye on those holes here and I'm going to
warm it up some more
okay right there something happened and
what happened is what we call a phase
transition we want from solid to liquid
in other words we want from ice to
liquid water and you'll notice what
happened when I did that so now the
water molecules are free to rotate so
you'll see some of them spinning
spinning around they're free to move
they don't have to stay in one spot
anymore those open spaces went away so
right now in the liquid state these
water molecules are free to bang into
each other and very slowly will migrate
around
okay one that I'm gonna refreeze it so
let's cool it down and we don't have the
big holes that we had before but here's
one down here it's a little one right
there so water molecules like to form
six-sided rings when they're in the
solid state and if you look at a
snowflake a snowflake is often six-sided
some are twelve sided and that six sided
symmetry comes from this it comes from
the fact that water molecules like to
assemble themselves with six-sided
symmetry even at the molecular level
okay so in a solid water molecules
they're not perfectly still but they're
in general are not moving very very
quickly they're not changing places with
their neighbors they're mostly staying
in the same spot when I warm it up they
are able to move around it's kind of
like this giant mosh pit of water
molecules they're all bumping into each
other and they are free to spin or move
around okay so I'm gonna heat it up more
so as I heat it up more what we're gonna
see is that they have more vibrational
energy they're spinning faster and
occasionally one of them breaks apart
from the herd and when that happens
we're seeing another phase transition
the transition between liquid and vapor
so at this particular temperature I can
see I've got a couple vapor molecules up
there and most of them are still
I'm going to heat it up some more
and as I heated up some more I can see
more and more of the water molecules
going into the vapor state now let me
cool it back down so I cool it back down
and as I cool it down one of the things
that's going to happen is the vapor that
I have is going to condense down here
with the liquid and we turn to the
liquid state and notice that right now
compared to where I just had the
temperature I have very little water
molecules up in the vapor State okay so
this relates to something we learned
about two lectures ago and we had that
chart looking at maximum possible mixing
ratio with temperature and what we said
at the time is at the higher the
temperature the higher the maximum
possible mixing ratio could be and this
is an illustration of that when I make
it hotter more water molecules can enter
the vapor state when I have a colder
less water molecules can enter the vapor
State so here I'm warming it up again
and we're starting to see more of those
water molecules enter the state as it is
a vapor so those are the things that
keep in mind when you're trying to
visualize water molecules in a solid
they are gonna stay in one spot they
still vibrate a little bit in liquid
it's like the mosh pit they're all
elbowing each other in the vapor they're
free to move around and they typically
move in a straight line until they hit
something else or hit each other so
we're going to get into evaporation now
and one of the things to keep in mind
with evaporation is that whenever you
have a body of liquid water that's
exposed to the atmosphere there are
always going to be water molecules
leaving that liquid water and going into
the atmosphere and at the same time
there will be water molecules leaving
the atmosphere and entering the liquid
this is going on all the time so anytime
you've got liquid water no matter how
big the body of water is
you've got water molecules leaving
you've got water molecules coming back
now temperature is what controls the
rate at which they leave see if you've
got really cold water the water
molecules in this glass have relatively
low kinetic energy meaning that they're
not moving very fast and because they're
not moving very fast it's more difficult
for them to leave
the liquid surface of the water whereas
this glass because it's hotter the water
molecules have more kinetic energy
they're moving faster and they escape
the surface of the water or more easier
so there's a higher flux of water
molecules leaving the hot water than
there is the cold water now this relates
to something that we've talked about a
couple of lectures ago if I have an
atmosphere sitting over the ocean and we
would call that big blob of air and air
mass so we've got a big blob of air
sending over the Pacific Ocean this air
mass will pick up water vapor out of the
Pacific Ocean
but the Pacific Ocean is pretty cold and
so even though it's picking up water
vapor out of the ocean it doesn't get
that much compared if that same air mass
was sitting over say that Gulf of Mexico
Gulf of Mexico because that ocean is
warmer has a higher flux of water vapor
entering the air mass that's sitting
above it so when we talked about how
dewpoint will change with wind direction
this is the reason why air mass sits
over a warm ocean it picks up way more
water than the air mass sits over a cold
ocean if the wind comes from the west it
blows in this relatively dry air our dew
points typically are low if the wind
comes from the east and blows in this
air with relatively high dew points and
our dew points go up so I'm going to
show a couple diagrams with arrows that
represent the fluxes of the water
molecules leaving versus the water of
water molecules that are
turning so in this case what I'm trying
to show here is that I've got about
twice as many of the water molecules
leaving as I do of those returning okay
that's what that means
so imagine I've got three glasses of
water and each glass of water is the
same temperature but in each case they
are in an environment of different
relative humidities so what you would
notice is that in each case the amount
of water molecules leaving the flux is
the same for each remember that's what
the red arrow stands for and it's
dependent on temperature and the
temperature is the same so all three red
arrows are the same but where we have
low relative humidities we actually see
very few water molecules returning
whereas with moderate humidities we see
more water molecules returning and when
we get to a hundred percent relative
humidity we see equal rates of those
leaving and those returning so if you
think about evaporation as a net loss of
water which glass is going to dry up
first
well this one is losing way more than
it's gaining so this one is going to dry
up first
and in fact relative humidity is
correlated to the evaporation rate so
when you have low relative humidities
you have rapid evaporation whereas when
you get to moderate relative humidities
the evaporation rate is slower and when
you get to 100% evaporate relative
humidity you actually get no evaporation
at all so for us in New Mexico in June
we typically have the highest
temperatures with the lowest dew points
and what that ends up with is very very
low relative humidities so we'll get
relative humidities sometimes 1% or less
now if you've ever mopped your floor in
June one of the things you may notice is
that your floor will dry just about as
fast as you can mop there's a very very
high evaporation rate when do we get
into the monsoon and
we'll talk about the monsoon in the
future lecture but the relative humidity
does go up we get more water in the
atmosphere the evaporation rate slows
down a little bit in your if you mop
your floor it takes a little longer for
it to dry now here's an example question
we have three sponges and each one have
the same amount of water in them and
each are the same temperature the only
difference is that each of these are in
a different environment of relative
humidity which sponge dries up first and
this one has the lowest relative
humidity so this sponge is going to dry
it first because it's evaporation rate
will be higher relative humidity of a
hundred percent is kind of a rare thing
especially here in New Mexico but I want
to talk about it a little bit because
it's kind of a weird to think about so
if you lived in an environment where the
relative humidity was a hundred percent
every time one water molecule leaves the
glass another one would immediately have
to return and take its place so what
that means is that it doesn't matter how
long you left this glass of water out it
would never ever ever evaporate however
let's imagine you had some way to go in
there and identify all the water
molecules let's say you could put little
tiny nametags and all the water
molecules and you and then you let it
sit there for days and weeks and months
and you could go in and you could check
and check who's in there what you would
notice as time went on as you'd see less
and less of the original water molecules
that were in your glass and they've all
been replaced by these strangers that
came in from the atmosphere so
eventually if you did if you let this
stay here long enough all of the water
molecules in your glass of water would
be gone and they'd all be replaced with
these new ones that came in from the
atmosphere okay for this next part you
need to use your imagination a little
bit and we're working up towards
something called latent heat but to get
there I have a goofy story that I have
to explain
just stick with me a little bit it'll
make sense in the end I hope so the
first thing I want you to imagine is
that the world is covered in these
little tiny microscopic boxes you can't
see them but if you could they have a
label on them each one says thermal
energy and these boxes are all over the
place but if you took a bunch of these
boxes and he started adding them to
something the thing you add them to
would get warmer so we start throwing
these boxes in this little pond the pond
would warm up however we could also
reach down into the pond and grab those
same boxes and pull them out and if you
took them away the pond would become
cooler so anything you add them to
becomes warmer anything you take them
away from becomes cooler okay so now
imagine that the water molecules they
live in this kingdom that they have and
there are these rules and the rules are
regarding these little boxes and the
first rule that they have is that if you
are ever in the vapor State you have to
carry one of these boxes a thermal
energy with you everywhere you go okay
doesn't matter how long you're in the
atmosphere it doesn't matter where you
go if you're in the vapor State you have
to carry a box with you at all times
no exceptions okay they're very strict
about this all right
so rule number two if you go from the
vapor state and land back into liquid
somewhere you have to release your box
into the liquid doesn't matter if you
landed in the ocean if you land in the
river if you land in someone's glass of
water you've got to release your box as
soon as you land that's the rule okay so
what that means is if you could look
really closely at a body of liquid water
you would see there are boxes of thermal
energy floating around from all the
water molecules that have landed and
then you'd see the water molecules
bouncing into each other like the
animation that we saw okay so these
boxes are just going to stay there until
somebody leaves because rule number
three is if you ever leave
liquid state you have to take a box of
thermal energy with you okay that's the
rule because to be in vapor state you
have to have a box so what they do is is
these boxes floating around it doesn't
matter whose is who is they don't keep
track it doesn't matter they're all the
same you just have to grab one before
you go okay so what this means is if we
think about fluxes of water molecules
leaving and returning if we've got more
guys leaving than we have coming back
these guys are pulling out more boxes of
thermal energy then these guys are
returning we have a net loss of thermal
energy we also have a net loss of water
molecules but if we do that because
we're removing more thermal energy than
we are replacing the liquid down here is
going to become cooler because it's
losing thermal energy as a net loss of
thermal energy on the other hand if we
had a situation where we had more of
these guys arriving dropping their boxes
off into the liquid then we had leaving
then we would have a net addition of
thermal energy and the liquid would warm
on account of this okay so depending on
the fluxes of how many you have leaving
and how many have coming back the body
of water could get cooler or could get
warmer so let's go over a couple
examples of how this works in real life
so as humans when we get hot we sweat
and the sweat is mostly water and the
water comes out you know it's exactly
the same temperature as your body so the
sweat by itself does not cool you but
your body is relying on the evaporation
and if the conditions are right then
when water molecules evaporate off of
your skin they are removing those little
units of thermal energy and the
remaining water the remaining sweat or
your skin becomes cooler which means
that if you're human and you're sweating
what relative
community conditions do you prefer so in
order for sweat to work you need rapid
evaporation rapid evaporation requires
low relative humidity so if you're
sweating it works best if you have low
relative humidity you've probably been
in a situation where you've been in high
relative humidity and hot temperatures
that's pretty miserable and one of the
reasons it's miserable is because your
sweat simply is not evaporating very
much so there's very little latent heat
being removed from your body there's
another example kind of in the opposite
direction so we've got a teapot here
there's water in there that's boiling
and what's coming out is water vapor
except you actually can't see water
vapor water vapor water vapor is
invisible and so we commonly refer to
this as steam and steam has several
definitions but one definition is that
it's a mixture of water vapor that you
cannot see and little tiny droplets of
liquid that you can see so the part we
can see is actually a little tiny
microscopic droplets but there's water
vapor in here for this example let's
imagine that this is all just water
vapor okay and so the water vapor is
coming out and if you are unfortunate
enough to put your hand in the stream of
water vapor that's coming out of the
teapot the individual water molecules
that come out are the temperature of
boiling water because that's where they
just came from and they land on your
hand and they transfer that heat to your
hand and that burns you right that's
that hurts but it's actually worse than
that because not only are they
transferring the heat that they
themselves are carrying but they're also
showing up with their little boxes of
thermal energy that they took out of the
water in the teapot and when they land
on your hand not only are they
transferring their high temperature to
your hand but they're also depositing
their little boxes of thermal energy so
you kind of have to imagine thermal
energy just be piling up on your hand as
these water molecules land on your hand
so you have the heat
of the hot water molecules plus you've
got the accumulated heat of all of their
thermal energy units being piled on so
this produces a steam burn in a steam
burn if you've ever had one especially
nasty because it's a burn that's hotter
than what you would get in boiling water
is the temperature of boiling water plus
extra thermal energy on top of that so
it's a really painful type of burn in
nature we talked about how do will form
if we cool the air below the dew point
and so what we talked about earlier a
couple of lectures ago is that as we
cool the temperatures off at night if we
get below the dew point we will start
growing do usually on a very thin
surface like grass well the other thing
that actually happens during this
process is that as the water molecules
come down to join this growing dew drop
they're adding their little boxes of
thermal energy to this drop in so the
formation to do actually adds heat to
the the grass so this is a little
confusing because we said you got you
got to cool the temperatures down to get
to the dew point and that's still true
but what we're saying now is as you make
do that's actually adding some heat back
into the environment it doesn't warm the
environment up but it prevents it from
cooling down as much as it normally
would so here's back to our sponge
question except I've I've changed it a
little bit so the beginning is the same
as we saw before so we have three
sponges each is wet each is the same
temperature each has the same amount of
water in it and the only difference is
the relative humidity next to each
sponge right so we have these three
sponges and we said before that this one
is the one that's going to evaporate
first so now the question is instead you
let them sit for 15 minutes and you
return to fine all three still damp
which one is the coldest so the relative
humidity here is the lowest this one
dries the first but not only is
evaporation the most rapid on this one
but we're also losing thermal energy
more rapidly on this one so when we come
back in 15 minutes this one will be the
driest and it will be the coldest
because it has lost the most thermal
energy so this concept that we've been
talking about where I invented this with
a world of boxes and X and all that that
is actually known as science is latent
heat in latent means hidden so latent
heat are these little packets of energy
that you cannot see but they're
transferred between water molecules when
they change phases so as they go from
from liquid to vapor and back from vapor
to liquid they transfer this energy back
and forth latent heat is a giant source
of energy in weather and climate so when
we when we look at say thunderstorms or
hurricanes part of the energy a big
chunk of the energy that's keeping those
storms going is actually latent heat
it's the is these little tiny packets of
energy being transferred from water
molecules as they go from one phase to
the other so it's a pretty big deal in
weather and climate a couple more
examples so humans we sweat and latent
heat is removed from our body dogs
cannot sweat so they pant and so what
dogs are relying on is the removal of
latent heat from their tongue so they
have a big wet sloppy tongue and the
evaporation occurs over the tongue and
water molecules remove latent heat from
their tongue and that cools their tongue
and there's blood vessels in their
tongue that then take that you know the
blood cools on their tongue and that
gets circulated throughout their body
and that's their cooling mechanism
there's a little bit of cooling as they
move air back and forth over the tongue
from the outside but the main purpose of
panting is to increase evaporation over
the tongue so if you have bullet hot
soup and you blow on the soup that's to
increase the evaporation rate that route
that removes extra latent heat so in a
in a
panting dog as the air moves back and
forth over his tongue it's increasing
the evaporation rate losing latent heat
to cool the dog or cat so what would a
dog rather have high relative humidity
or low relative humidity and so just
like us in order for their panting to be
effective like our sweating to be
effective they prefer to be in the low
relative humidity environments so if you
have a dog and you live in a place with
high relative humidity and he's panting
his panting probably isn't doing much
good as a little dog you bringing
doesn't know this but he's panting and
panting and panting like he thinks it's
gonna help it's just not helping because
wait and he is not being removed from
his tongue like he's expecting so a dog
in a environment that's hot with a
hundred percent relative humidity has no
way of cooling himself and for us in
terms of if we were sweating in an
environment of 100% relative humidity
we can't cool ourselves either so if you
live in New Mexico or almost anywhere in
the in the southwest you probably have
something called a swamp cooler on your
roof also known as an evaporative cooler
and inside this cooler on around each of
the four sometimes they have three sighs
some things they have four sides there
are these what look like giant sponges
that we call pads and inside the pads
are kept wet so there's a pool of water
underneath so this is what you cut one
open this is what it looks like there so
this is filled with water down here and
there's a whole fountain and it dribbles
the water down there's the pads right
there and it keeps them wet then this
thing is a big motor big fan that sucks
air and it sucks air in and it boils it
down into the house so that's what this
is okay so the air comes in through the
pads and as it comes in through the pads
the the wetness of this of the pad
causes evaporation so water is
evaporating from these pads and as it
does so the evaporation removes thermal
energy removes latent heat and the
result the residual water
the left is cooler and as the air runs
through that cooler pad it cools the air
so in my animation here I have water
molecules leaving and going up in the
atmosphere some do that but a lot of
them actually go the evaporate into the
air that is then pushed into your house
so part of the result of this is that it
actually adds water vapor to the air in
your house so typically you know this
might be the setup it might be United
five degrees outside only 10 percent
relative humidity the air gets drawn in
goes to the wet pads evaporation occurs
cooling occurs remove of latent heat
occurs and then that the air now is
maybe 15 degrees colder than it was but
now it's the relative humidity is higher
and for two reasons
number one as we learned in the previous
lecture if I just cool the temperature
down I will increase relative humidity
and number two a lot of the evaporation
that takes place actually adds water to
the air that's going through the swamp
cooler itself so the air that's coming
into your house has more water vapor in
the air itself and so you have a higher
relative humidity and a higher mixing
ratio and a higher dew point inside your
house as a result so we have these all
over the Southwest and this is a map of
relative humidity of the entire country
and this is a national average average
over a whole whole year so what you'll
see here now if we can read this but it
says relative humidity percent and this
is says 20 to 35 and then the 30 is 40s
50s 70s and this is average again over
the whole year so the winter and summer
the whole thing but what you notice is
that right here this area that kind of
brownish area this is the area that has
the lowest relative humidity in the
country and if you have a swamp cooler
an evaporative cooler this is the part
of the world the part of the country
sorry that it's actually going to work
best because if I go back if the
relative humidity is too high I don't
have much evaporation if I don't have
much evaporation I don't have
much cooling so the only way this thing
works is if I have very low relative
humidities once you get out into this
part of the country
nobody has swamp coolers people down
here don't even know the swamp core it
is they've never seen one because if you
built one you put one on your house it
would do nothing because you've got like
like that green zone right there that's
relative humidities that are routinely
over 80% if you had a swamp cooler and
you turn it on there'd be so little
evaporation you notice no cooling effect
at all so really realistically when we
get really kind of east of the Sandia
Mountains kind of right through here
nobody over here has swamp cores because
they just are very ineffective this area
the desert southwest of swamp coolers
worked especially during those months
with a little relative humidity so why
do we have that instead of normal
refrigerated air because everybody over
here has what we call air conditioning
normal refrigerated air the advantage of
swamp coolers is they are cheaper to
make and they're cheaper to run so they
don't require nearly as much electricity
as refrigerated air so you could put
refrigerated air on your house and it
would be colder but it also cost a lot
more so that's why you see a lot of
these swamp coolers in this part of the
country they are cheap to build and
they're cheap to run and they work
because we have low relative humidity
okay so take-home points from this whole
lecture water molecules are always
leaving and entering the surface of a
liquid all times and depending on the
temperature the flux of water molecules
you know there's height there's a higher
flux of water leaving warmer water than
there there is cooler water the rate of
the molecules returning is controlled by
relative humidity right so the higher
the relative humidity the more water
molecules are coming back the lower the
relative humidity the higher the
evaporation rate so we talked about that
and then when water exchanges phases it
exchanges these small little invisible
packets of energy that we call thermal
energy and so I made up the whole story
with the little boxes so they
you can visualize that just to make sure
we're Claire there are no little tiny
boxes that say thermal energy lying
around okay that's a whole visual so you
can kind of understand the concept but
when water makes transitions between
phases it transfers these little packets
of energy along we call that latent heat
evaporation removes latent heat
condensation adds latent heat alright so
next time we will talk about how all of
this works to make clouds thanks for
watching
you